the phone lines are on fire right now
you should see the phone bill i'm about
to get let's go back to the phone lines
at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty let's
check in with
dantel from florida last time when
dontel called in we went to dontel
and the line was dead but i'm glad to
see that dontel is back
what's going on with you um
hey so i wanted to talk about um kind of
the direction of the the lesbian
movement in the country
sure so like so yeah
a lot of people on the left myself
included made the calculation a while
ago
that the best strategy to get social
democratic policies implemented
would be by uh taking over the
democratic party okay
like with groups of justice democrats
our revolution
but now that we're in a pandemic
unprecedented economic crisis
we're literally in a political reality
that no one could have ever expected or
anticipated
so and the elected progressives they
failed miserably
they've got no major policy wins and by
their own admission
they don't even plan on getting like
important policies like medicare for all
ubi
debt and rent cancellation for at least
four years
maybe even longer than that so
how effective do you think the
progressive takeover the democratic
party has been
and do you think that the majority of
the country
that was already living on the brink
before the the all of this happened
do you think that they can go another
four years without medicare parole or
ubi
or rent cancellation so i mean there's a
lot of questions in there dantel the
first thing is d
did you say something about canceling
everyone's rent for four years everybody
lives rent free for four years
or are these governments subsidized okay
yeah i
i've not even heard that proposed who
proposed that
yeah that's the thing nobody's proposing
it oh you want it oh i'm sorry you want
rent cancelled for four years
there by all estimates at least
28 million or 23 million people are
expected to be
evicted by october yes so
this this is as a result of the pandemic
and economic crisis
and neither of them are going anywhere
anytime soon right
so it does make sense to cancel rent
or at least have government subsidize
rent for the duration of the crisis
okay yeah i just i guess i just i think
four years is a non-starter and i don't
think the crisis is going to last four
years i hope
four years i said they think that the
elected progressives
their plan isn't to get any medicare for
all the ubi or anything like that for at
least four years till they have some
sort of super majority i guess oh i
misunderstood you dantel i'm sorry you
weren't proposing canceling it for
four years you were saying there's not
going to be any proposal to do it
for the four years that joe biden would
be president i think now i understand
you right
yeah okay so listen um progressive
takeover the progressive takeover of the
democratic party
i think that a lot of this is about
managing expectations
and i know you and i dantel have had our
differences
over the you know time that you've been
calling in but
and this may be one of them my
perspective is
that the progressive takeover you would
like to see
may not be in line with what most
democratic voters actually want and what
i would point to is that
biden really won the primary not by a
little but really by quite a bit i mean
he was up 2 million votes
at the point at which bernie kind of
started to
white flag and so i'm coming at it from
a different approach
which i'm obviously glad to hear how you
disagree with it but
my approach is uh joe biden
said that he would use the green new
deal as a framework for his climate plan
and he he has to a great degree and in
fact there were bernie supporters
who were mad that he copied stuff from
bernie on climate it's like that's good
i want him copying stuff from bernie on
climate
in terms of his tax plan it's a far more
progressive tax plan than what barack
obama
wanted and if it becomes a reality it
would be a significant incremental step
i mean a limiting eliminating stepped-up
basis
and capital gains you know a lot of
different things so
we might have different expectations and
that's okay
i want to work together with with folks
with your perspective dantel
but i think that when we talk about a
progressive takeover
we're probably talking about two
different things and as you're defining
it we're not going to see it under joe
biden that's for sure
are we going to see the most progressive
platform of any president in history
if biden is elected right not if not
platforms that have been proposed
but of an actual office holder that's
what biden would be
if he wins i
i know what you're saying about that and
to the first one
that you made about um the democratic
party
the voters in the democratic party
aren't as left as as myself or as i
think that they are
i i strongly disagree with that if you
look at the exit polls from
basically every state in the primary
medicare for all was
in the majority and that was even before
we had a a public health crisis like a
deadly global pandemic yep so i think
that
it's not a matter of the voters i think
it's just it's not working
in the democratic party that may be now
can i just push back a little bit about
what you said so you
if i i want to make sure i understand
what you said yeah you said
you see you believe that the the
democratic party
actually is as left as you believe it to
be and as evidence you said that the
exit polls
showed a majority want medicare for all
did i understand you correctly
yeah okay so the polls
i've looked at do show a slight majority
of support for medicare for all in the
democratic party
when no information is given but as more
information is given about how it would
work
the support goes down to the low 40s
high 30s
so i may be looking at different data
than you
but i don't know that that's the proof
you're necessarily looking at
um i'm not sure i agree with that
because
the way that a lot of people frame it
like certain um posters when they ask
the question they ask it in a
they frame it in a way like oh i do you
want to kick everybody
in the country off their private health
insurance yeah but i'm not talking about
those polls no i know those polls are
those are push-pulls and those are not
trustworthy but there's good data like
for example there's a great powerpoint
from the kaiser family foundation which
which has nothing to do with kaiser
permanente it just happens to both be
called kaiser
um and they don't do that and they show
that as people learn more
about what medicare for all entails
support does go down to about thirty
eight thirty nine percent
okay you did it and um so one was the
last thing um because i feel like you
could never have enough time
to to finish these conversations sure um
i
have a small youtube channel uh it's
called unapologetic
and uh about like 2 600 subscribers and
so i was just wondering if
you'd like to have me on the show to do
like an interview or a segment or
something that we could
talk about some of these issues in more
detail well you're on the show right now
dantel you're one of our most frequent
callers you've been on so much
yeah but i feel like it's so pressure to
try to get
every like all the points that i want to
make into a
half of a six minute segment so right
now
but you know everything about that when
things calm down a little right now i'm
not
you know let's explore that when things
calm down a little how about that all
right but i appreciate
the call to the show and you've taken my
calls for
over a year now um yeah so thank you all
right dontel
dontel from florida um there he is
uh he speaks for himself i don't have to
say anything else about it